- This is so weird!
- Wow, it's so weird, the interviewer
becomes the interviewee.
- I know.
The tables have turned.
- The tables have turned.
- Do you remember anything
from our day-drinking day?
- Well, I remember being
drunk enough that I thought
I was hittin' all those notes.
(audience laughs)
- (laughs) You were almost there!
- [Seth] I was almost there.
- That's like awesome.
- I feel like it's a lot,
I think I coulda done it,
if you weren't lookin' right at me.
- Okay, I was, and I was laughing,
but I was drunk.
- Yeah.
I remember that after you
left, I went to my producer,
and I said, "I feel terrible
"I forgot to say goodbye to Kelly."
and he said, "You have
said goodbye to her twice."
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
"And each time you said
the exact same thing,
"as if the first time hadn't happened."
(audience laughs)
- I think we both did that though,
'cause I said that to my people.
I was like, "I was
nice, I was respectable.
"I said bye, right?"
And my husband was like,
"Just, let's just go."
- [Seth] Yeah.
- Like it was, I have never,
I've never been drinking in the day.
- Yeah.
- You are my only time I've ever drank,
even now, I don't drink during the day,
'cause I'm usually working.
- Yeah, most people work during the day.
(audience laughs)
Don't judge yourself too harshly.
- [Kelly] No.
- At least your husband was there
so he could see what happens.
What happens with me is I've never not
gotten into a minor fight with
my wife after day-drinking,
because she's at home with the two kids,
and then I come home, again, at 2:30,
and I like walk in all drunk,
and I knock a lamp over.
- And you've gotta speak.
- And she'll be like,
"What's wrong with you?"
and I'm like, "It was for work!"
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
"I was working!"
- You're welcome!
- "You're welcome!
"This drinking puts clothes on our kids!"
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- No one has a problem, it's fine.